salut aujourd'hui c'est le jour de
l'explication de la semaine le jour vous
m'avez avouez vous regarder souvent
cette vidéo dans votre lit le dimanche
matin à 11 heures quand elle sort elle
sort tous les dimanches à 11h celle ci
alors je me suis dit comme ça dimanche
je fais la vidéo depuis mon canapé ça me
donne l'illusion aussi d'être un
dimanche où je fais pas grand chose
je crois qu'on a trouvé leur rythme de
croisière sur la chaîne vous avez
remarqué ça le lundi je mentalise
quelqu'un en vidéo le mardi également le
mercredi je donne toujours une astuce
pour devenir un peu plus mentalisme
jeudi maintenant c'est le nouveau
rendez-vous je parle d' un peu ce que je
veux le vendredi je mentalise encore
quelqu'un que je rencontrais dans ma
semaine le samedi c'est le master class
les vidéos un petit peu plus longue et
le dimanche ce sont les explications je
vous explique toujours quelque chose qui
va vous permettre de bluffer quelqu'un
directement au repas vous allez faire
peut-être dans la journée ou dans votre
semaine cette semaine c'est pas une
explication de mentalisme et de magie
mentale c'est quasiment la même chose
ils ont ils sont assez voisin l'année
l'autre pour ça je vais prendre un jeu
de cartes
le s p est ce que vous vous souvenez
bien de ce qu'est un symbole esp ce sont
les cartes deux nerfs vous savez avec la
croix le cercle les vagues l'étoile et
le carré on en a parlé sur une autre
vidéo d'un dimanche c'est bien ce coup
ci c'est carte là vont nous permettre de
maîtriser le hasard voilà je pensais à
ça hier je pense que ça peut vous
intéresser pour faire cet effet à vos
amis vous avez soit besoin d'acheter un
jeu de cartes esp vous tapez za sur
internet jeux de cartes respect vous
trouvez vous en recommande pas un en
particulier
mais vous pouvez faire la même chose
vous même en prenant des papiers soit
que vous découpez soit des petites comme
des cartes de visite aussi aux deux
cartes de vie voilà peu importe le
format
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'en avoir 52 en
fait pour en avoir juste une trentaine
ou une quarantaine n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir un nombre précis pour faire ça
comme ça je suis certain que vous
pourrez le faire vous aussi comme
d'habitude je vous fait d'avoir la
démonstration pour que vous puissiez
bien vivre les faits et ensuite je vous
explique ce sera rapide
imaginons que j'ai quelqu'un après deux
mois salut lui fabien est ce que tu veux
bien mélanger ce jeu là pour moi ce sont
des cartes esp j'étais trop le temps de
m'expliquer ce que c'est mais si on
regarde les vidéos de badoo mois en fait
je me perds dans mes jeux mais j'ai déjà
regardé la vidéo fabien tu imagines
d'homme je suis abonné alors je te
mélange de cartes n'y a pas de problème
c'est vrai tu mélange très très bien
merci à toi j'ai devenir schizophrène
moi alors je vais sortir cinq cartes du
jeu pas n'importe lesquels évidemment je
vais sortir une étoile un rond autour
des vagues
et je vais les mettre ici étoiles carey
croit bon comme je te plumerai soir là
je vais vous expliquer le du jeu
maintenant c'est d'expliquer à votre
spectateurs qui va devoir remettre les
cartes comme ceux ci en face mais un peu
dans l'ordre qu'il veut il peut faire un
peu n'importe quoi en fait jusqu'à temps
qu'il n'y ait plus de cartes donc
imaginantes face à l'as il en met une
dizaine ici là il aimait une par une il
revient là il revient là et bien là là
là et ici c'est magnifique place ont
ensuite les cartes pass en l'air sur les
petits tas qui ont été faits et pour
chaque cas on va couper et remettre la
coupe sur le dessus et enfin de réunir
toutes les cartes ont un seul paquet
c'est à dire on repose les cartes dans
lors qu'on veut pour avoir au final un
seul gros paquet comme ça ce test de
perception extra sensorielle nous permet
de voir si notre spectateurs sur une
échelle de un à cinq a une perception
particulière des choses et pour vérifier
ça pour regarder ça on va faire défiler
le jeu et à chaque fois qu'on a une
carte en l'air pour mada sortir avec la
carte en bas qui est juste au-dessus
idem
là je vais prendre la carte qui efface
en l'air avec la carte qui est juste sur
le dessus pareil pour la troisième
pareil pour la 4e et enfin pareil pour
la cinquième ce jeu était évidemment
composé de tous les symboles des
quartiers est et mélanger les uns aux
autres et pourtant grâce à la perception
étrange et fascinante de votre
spectateurs si on retourne la carte des
vagues sur le dessus il y avait là
quartier des factions retourne la carte
étoiles sur le dessus il y avait la
carte étoiles sur la carte croit il y
avait la carte 3 sur la carte car il y
avait la carte car est évidemment et sur
la carte rond nous avions également la
carte rond c'est pas mystérieux ça
malgré tout les coupes et les mélanges
qui ont été faits le spectateur a réussi
à réunir les cinq cartes avec sa
distribution à lui du moins c'est ce
qu'il croit parce que vous y êtes un
petit peu pour quelque chose nous
passons maintenant à la partie
explications étape numéro une vous
donner le jeu réellement a mélangé à un
spectateur et ensuite c'est la seule
chose importante que vous ayez salut
c'est la seule chose importante que vous
ayez à faire pour la suite donc
retenez bien ça vous allez prendre le
jeu face à vous les spectateurs ne doit
pas pouvoir forcément ce que vous faites
et vous allez mettre les cinq symboles
esp différent ici devant vous sur votre
table mais vous devez secrètement faire
en sorte également que les cinq premiers
carte soit les cinq symboles esp
différence n'est pas le cas pour moi
mais je vous faire voir comment on règle
ce léger problème vous passez la
première carte c'est le carré vous la
gardez en main la célèbre jeu lagarde en
main le cercle guerlain crois je garde
en main car et je l'est déjà
donc au lieu de les garder en main je
vais le poser sur la table ensuite les
toiles je ne l'avais pas donc je la
garde ici et maintenant je veux juste
aller chercher à mettre les cinq
symboles différents sur la table donc
j'ai cinq symboles différents sur la
table et les cinq premières cartes que
j'ai dans les mains sont aussi cinq
symboles je retiens l'ordre je retiens
l'ordre mois pour retenir lors d'une
technique très simple si vous souvenez
de la vidéo où je vous apprenez à vous
servir de ça pour deviner un dessin et
j'utilise mon comptage c'est à dire que
là je me dis 4 comme c'est le carré 4 3
parce qu'il ya trois vagues
1 parce qu'il ya juste un seul trait 2
parce qu'il ya deux traits et 5 passes
qui a cinq traits donc je retiens 43 je
retiens 14 et 1 je retiens 5 43 14
de toute manière je retiens que quelques
secondes vous allez voir pourquoi parce
que là je vais tout remettre dans le
même ordre en fait ici je prends mon 43
et ça récapitulatif parce qu'après c'est
très simple j'ai mis sur la table 5
cartes pas dans n'importe quel symbole
dans le même symbole que mes cinq
premières cartes de mon paquet mais cinq
cartes différentes donc si je vérifie
j'ai bien le carré les vagues
le cercle lacroix et l'étoile maintenant
vous allez expliquer à votre spectateurs
ce qui doit faire donc vous prenez des
cartes une par une en disant tu vas
mettre les cartes à chaque fois devant
les symboles que j'ai me fasse en l'air
en faisant tout ce que tu veux dans
l'ordre que tu veux tu peux en mettre
plusieurs d'un coup une ici de la une la
c'est tout comme tu veux le fait de me
montrer ce qu'il a à faire ça à deux
sens le sens réel qui est de lui
expliquer et le sens caché qui est le
fait d'avoir ni devant chaque carte
la première carte que vous avez posé
devant chaque cas c'est la carte
correspondant sur la carte d'identité et
ça c'est la clé de cet effet ensuite
voulu demander de mettre sur chaque
paquet correspondant la carte qui efface
en l'air juste en face et à chaque fois
de faire une coupe et de compléter cette
coupe c'est à dire que là par exemple je
fais une coupe
et je complète la coupe comme ceux ci
étaient ça pour les cinq paquets
dernière étape vous lui demander de
réunir tous les paquets dans l'ordre qui
veut en fait n'a pas d'importance
il récupère les cinq paquets pour
n'avoir plus qu'un seul et c'est terminé
c'est que vous avez ramené sur les
cartes qui étaient face en l'air la
carte identique que vous avez posé juste
avant ce qui fait que si vous étalez le
jeu soit sur une table soit dans vos
mains et que vous sortez les cartes
faces en l'air avec la première carte
qui est sur la carte face en l'air comme
ceux ci vérifie automatiquement aboutir
un repas de soutien sur cette réussite
de votre secteur
à savoir il leur a mis sur le carré le
carré sur la croix la croix sur les
vagues
les vagues sur les toiles l'étoile et
enfin sur le cercle que le surprise un
cercle félicité bien votre spectateurs
pour ce petit miracle parce que c'est
lui qui a travaillé vous n'avez rien à
en retirer
c'est lui qu'il faut applaudir j'espère
que cette explication vous aura plus que
vous allez essayer de le faire sur
d'autres personnes n'hésitez pas à
acheter un jeu ou à faire vous même des
cartes sur des bouts de papier vous
prenez une feuille a4 vous l'a découpé
en 16 pareil cas une étude avec une
deuxième ça vous fait un jeu de 32
cartes c'est très bien si cette vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit pouce en l'air et surtout à vous
abonner abonnez-vous à la chaîne je
compte sur vous pour le faire partager
cette vidéo autant que vous voulez si
vous essayez de faire cet effet sur
quelqu'un raconter mois dans les
commentaires comment ça s'est passé est
ce que la personne a aimé est ce que
vous êtes fait avoir à ce que vous avez
raté réussi j'adore lire tout ça j'adore
lire vos retours d'expériences passées
un excellent dimanche et rendez vous
demain à 17h sur cette chaîne youtube
ciao